prime minister Orban sat down with
Tucker and this is the I you know I love
Tucker and but I I feel such Envy
because I was just over there for a few
days and I want to sit down with Victor
Orban maybe next time I go to to Hungary
I will be able to do that uh but at the
very least we got this excellent
excellent interview from Tucker highly
recommended must watch in which Orban
discusses not just the Divide between
the East and the west or China and the
west but a big divide within the West
it's more about our civilization I mean
the Western Christian Civilization now
the main division line is not according
to ideologies it's a it's it's deeper it
has an anthropological character so on
one side in Europe and probably in your
country but in Europe definitely there
are groups of people who think that the
most important thing of the word is
their ego themselves me this this is the
center of the world the
other Camp of the people the other part
of of the society think that it's not
true because there are certain things
which are more important than me than my
ego family Nation God and because they
are more important than me I have to
serve this higher level things so this
Society has a majority here in Hungary
and the other society which is
concentrating only me you know only
dealing with myself it's it's more
westernized
dominating factor of the political life
so insightful one thing I really admire
about Orban is he's a a seriously
intelligent educated person who takes
knowledge and learning and wisdom very
seriously and I know that seems really
basic you would hope that all your
Statesmen would do that but they don't
they patently don't and the other thing
I like is is he's not just some
completely disconnected intellectual in
an ivory Tower somewhere he's a
Statesman he's a guy in the Rough and
Tumble of politics but he takes these
broad historical and philosophical
questions questions very seriously and
he can simplify it this is one of the
signs that that somebody knows what he's
talking about is when he can take a
complex matter like this anthropological
divide within western civilization and
distill it down in really simple terms
here's the Divide people who think that
I me my is the most important thing on
earth and people who think that there
are more important things than me simple
enough and it's so true I think even if
you caught the
Western liberals and liberal leaning
so-called conservatives if you caught
them in a moment of cander maybe you got
them after a couple of drinks they would
admit this they would be proud of this
they would say yes of course I exist to
fulfill myself I'm interested not in
caring for my family and community and
Country I'm interested in self-love I
need self-care you know it's just I'm
GNA I'm going to take care of me now Kim
Kardashian said this after her divorce
she said in my 40s I'm finally going to
I'm gonna take care of
myself as though she she was Mother
Teresa before that but now she's going
to take care of herself and it's not
just the left it's the right it's the
right under the influence of people like
Ein Rand the right under the influence
of an a hyper individualism the right
under the influence of libertarianism
which
says yeah me I me my greed is good I'm
just going to pursue my own interests
you leave me alone you can't tell me
what to do I'm entitled to do whatever I
want that's my freedom that's my Liberty
that's not the classical Western
understanding of Liberty that's not the
Christian understanding of Liberty but
it is the modern liberal conception it's
exactly what prime minister Orban is
talking about and he says look that's a
view he's he's obviously criticizing it
but he's more just describing it he's
saying that is the dominant view in the
west but we have a different view right
now go to medishare.com as a dailywire
listener you are not just in informed
you're engaged and you value freedom and
personal responsibility that's why we
think you will like Medishare Medishare
is a community- based approach to
healthcare that lines up with the
principles you believe in your values
matter and with Medishare your
Healthcare dollars won't be used for
medical procedures that don't line up
with your beliefs Medishare is the
highest rated Healthcare sharing
Ministry with a 30-year proven track
record it's not health insurance it's a
community of 400,000 Believers committed
to caring and sharing with one another
members save up to 50 % or more on their
monthly healthcare costs for a limited
time daily wire listeners will receive a
$150 gift card when you join Medishare
to find out more go to medishare.com m i
c h AEL that is medishare.com
terms and conditions apply so head on
over there right now go to medishare.com
and get a
$150 gift card we have a different view
which is much as I want to pursue my own
individual interests much as I like
myself much as I have certain desires I
recognize some things are more important
namely family country and God family is
the basic political Community man going
back there's a big distinction between
liberalism classical modern and
otherwise and the classical Christian
tradition liberalism says the basic unit
of society is the individual chrisan it
and Aristotle and classical
understandings of politics say that the
basic unit of society is the family and
it's the family because politics is
public so it involves other people says
that man is a political creature The
Social Animal okay big difference so
Orban says starts with the family and
then goes to love of country and the
importance of nation right because
that's an extension of the family it's
an extension of the kins folk and and
the tribe and and your patriotism is an
extension of filial piety and ultimately
what this is what this is ordered toward
is God because some things are good and
true and beautiful and we should want to
seek those and some things are
destructive and ugly and false and not
conducive to our flourishing and we
should avoid those and the name for
Truth For Truth himself is God is Jesus
and the name for the highest good the
summum bonum in to use an older Latin
phrase is God so that's what we're going
to orient all of our political efforts
toward really basic stuff
and or or orbon I really like he's so
cleare eyed about this he's really
humble about it because he'll say look
we're a country of 10 million people
we're not going to lead anything we're
not we're not going to be the dominant
hegemonic power ever we don't we're
landlocked are you kidding me but
because of the unique circumstances of
Hungary it's got this weird language
that nobody speaks it's a pretty
coherent people the country is 1100
years old we've been able to preserve
this thing and maybe we could look and
learn some lessons because there's one
statistic that shows
you how these ideas are playing out in
society every single country in the west
is dying is literally dying not having
enough people to replace themselves and
the birth rates generally continue to
plummet
one country has started to turn the
birth rate problem around coincidentally
it's the one that says imimi is not the
top priority family country and God is
pretty simple stuff I'm not saying it's
easy to implement but it's pretty simple
man what a great clip that was now make
sure that you ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll
see you next time